de de szerintem ez lesz a jövő tehát
hogyha most nem is ebben a választási
ciklusban de négy év múlva romániában is
szerintem az lesz hogy hogy lesznek majd
ezek a nagyon híres és hitelesnek
tartott műsorvezetők és akkor mint ahogy
most drágos petráru is egy egy
hitelesnek tartott valaki és akkor
gyakorlatilag ha nem mész el az is
elmond valamit rólad ha elmész akkor
pedig egy csomó minden ki fog derülni
igen egyet étek egyértelműen tehát
mondom bennem is megvan ez a kíváncsiság
nagyon kíváncsi vagyok hov tart de
visszaugorva az első gondolatomra én
nagyon örvendek főleg azért is örvendek
mert részesei lehetünk ennek és és
nagyon vagány
dolgoki jöhetnek ebből az egész
történetből a következő évekbe